we are heading as you know to uh Israel
and I'm going with a very simple and
clear message on behalf of the president
of the United States and on behalf of
the American people and that is that the
United States has Israel's back we have
the back of the Israeli people we have
their back today we'll have it tomorrow
we will have it every day we stand
resolutely against
terrorism we've seen the almost
undescribable acts committed by Hamas
against Israeli men women and children
every today we're learning more and it
is simply
heartbreaking not since Isis have we
seen this kind of depravity and we will
continue to stand very resolutely
against it uh when I'm in Israel I'll
have the opportunity to meet with prime
minister Netanyahu president Herzog uh
other senior officials uh I look forward
to seeing our Embassy team uh as well
that's been doing terrific work during
uh these difficult days um we're
determined to make sure that Israel gets
everything it needs to defend itself to
provide for the security of its people
already significant military assistance
requested by Israel is on the way that's
on top of everything that we've been
doing uh for years including with the
memorandum of understanding that was
negotiated by President Obama uh to make
sure that Israel has what it needs to
defend itself uh at the same time uh we
anticipate there'll be further needs
further requests we've already been
working closely with Congress on this
and we look forward to continuing to do
that to make sure that Israel has what
it needs second we will be reiterating
reaffirming the very strong message that
President Biden has delivered to any
country or any party that might try to
take advantage of this situation and
that message is don't uh president has
deployed as you know uh the world's
largest aircraft carrier group to the
region to make very clear our intent to
deter anyone contemplating any further
aggression uh against
Israel uh finally we're of course very
focused on our own people
our own citizens we lost 22
Americans that number could still go up
and it probably will at the same time we
have a number of Americans who remain
unaccounted uh we are working very
closely with the government of Israel to
determine their whereabouts and if they
have been taken hostage by Hamas uh to
work to secure their release so all of
these things are on the agenda over the
next U the next day or so with Israel
but the main point is this we stand with
Israel we'll continue to do so thank you
Mr secretary uh yesterday Jake Sullivan
said the US officials were talking to
the Israelis about getting civilian safe
passage uh through uh through Gaza into
Egypt uh today John Kirby said they're
still talking to the officials about
this uh what is the hold up what's the
obstacle to getting civilian safe
passage out of Gaza John we are we are
talking about that and we're talking to
uh Israel about that we're talking to
Egypt about that uh it's an ongoing
conversation I can't get into the
details um some of this is needless to
say and understandably complicated but
we want to make sure to the best of our
ability and I know Israel wants to make
sure to the best of its ability that
civilians uh are not harmed but uh
Israel has to take steps to defend
itself uh it has to make sure that uh
any ongoing threat is dealt with uh and
I believe it has to make sure that um
going forward uh what happened doesn't
happen again is the issue more on the
Israeli side or the Egypt side I'm not
going to get into the details but it's
an ongoing conversation uh following up
on that um in conversations between the
US and Israel has the US advocated any
degree of restraint in terms of possible
ground operations in Gaza either for the
sake of the civilians there or for the
sake of hostages in there well again I'm
not getting into any of the operational
details of what uh Israel May or or may
not do I think you heard the president
speak to this yesterday and his very
very strong and forceful comments um and
of course what separates Israel the
United States and other democracies when
it comes to incredibly difficult
situations like this is our respect for
international law uh and as appropriate
uh the laws of War uh we do everything
we can to make sure that in these
situations we avoid civilian casualties
that is in direct contrast uh with uh
Hamas which uses uh people as human
shields uh it um actually
seeks uh to be uh put Palestinian
civilians and
situations uh where they could be harmed
uh this is very much part of their uh
part of their game plan so uh we uh we
know that Israel will take uh all of the
precautions that uh that it can just as
we would and again that's what separates
us from Hamas and uh terrorist groups
that engage in the most heinous kind of
uh kind of activities thank you thank
you we'll have a chance to talk later
thank you all right that was a US
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin
speaking from the tarmac uh of The Joint
Base Andrews just as he gets ready to
take off he's headed to Israel um and so
he will be there uh tomorrow Marwan
bishara aljaz senior political analyst
you're joining us from Paris Marwan I'm
just going to for people joining us now
I'm just going to recap real quick what
blinkin said he said he himself said
look the most important thing I'm saying
here is that we fully have Israel's back
um but number one in a little bit more
detailed uh the US has determined that
Israel will get everything it needs to
defend itself and they anticipate that
there will be further needs I suppose
he's talking about the military needs
since they're already providing military
aid number two he reiterated President
Biden's message to countries or
organizations that would seek to take
advantage of this uh to harm Israel the
message is don't we heard that yesterday
you and I were talking about it and
number three uh the US is trying to
determine the whereabouts of missing US
citizens and um trying to figure out
whether or not they were taken captive
by Hamas short remarks before he heads
over to Israel your thoughts on this
trip America sending its top Diplomat to
Israel uh just also a quick note about
what he said last which you uh did not
mention about how he about how the
United States and Israel respect
international law and the laws of war
and uh we just had right before this
newsour we had two senior legal Scholars
on Inside Story and for half an hour
they explained how Israel is already in
breach of international law and breach
of international humanitarian law in the
way it is bombing uh Gaza and in the way
it is blockading Gaza and in the way it
is cutting food Fuel and goods from Gaza
so already we are I have two Scholars
that have made the call that Israel is
in breach of international law so a
secretary of state probably should
update his information second if they
are so much uh in respect of
international law why don't Israel and
the United States join the international
criminal court why are the United States
of Israel still outside the
international criminal court anyway
that's for the legal aspect of it but in
as far as what he said about the
unconditional support look this is
what's been really bothering me for the
last few days because understanding as a
student of us Israel relations for the
past you know five decades plus when
really they became strategic is that
America was always the grown-up in the
room America was always the grownup in
the room when Israel acts like the Rogue
state is it was the United States that
would come in and say no no no we should
do it this way we should the other way
there is respect for you resolution and
so on so forth this very particular
Biden Administration that was really in
a in a hostile relationship with with
for the past several months decided now
to be more Royal than the king providing
unconditional support telling Israel do
whatever it takes as long as it takes
which really meant so far just in the
last 48 hours war crimes against the
Palestinians so the American position is
is really becoming quite problematic
because it is not only not neutral and
not the grown up in the room it's
actually helping ex escalate the the the
the the war even further it is not
calling for a ceasefire you would expect
him to call for a ceas far and last but
not least his bit about the aircraft
carrier and once again they're issuing
ultimatums and threats to anyone who
would dare take advantage of the
situation and I think just judging for
the past 24 hours hisbah and Israel are
already
exchanging kind of very strange you know
chat through bombs right between them
and that could easily escalate out
control which begs the question is the
United States going to use its Ford
Naval Strike uh aircraft carrier to
start bombing Lebanon or Syria is is are
we going there already and what happens
when Israel starts its uh Invasion land
invasion of Gaza that you and I just
dropped before the secretary started
talking because
already American major right an a
military analyst a former American major
who senior in those sorts of questions
is predicting and I'm quoting tens of
thousands perhaps hundreds of thousands
of
deaths out of this war if the land
Invasion happens and Israel wants to
secure the inhilation of Hamas with
maximum security for its soldiers
because it's going to have to use tanks
and artillery and so on so forth so
already the military analysts are
telling us that if the if the land
invasion goes as apparently it will
because Galant has already announced it
to Israel's soldiers in a video already
is online that we are going the next
stage is is land invasion is which means
that is going to be apparently ACC again
according to the military an American
Military
analysts that this is going to be the
worst sort
of sort of urban Warfare since Second
World War